(audience applauding and cheering)
- See you're here in person.
- Good to see you.
You have some fans.
- We have many-
- Oh my God.
What have you been feeding them?
- Well, I think a dose of you, sir.
We have men and women
very excited you're here.
This is fantastic.
- Yeah, I know.
Well, it's your sixth season.
People are into your show.
We're very -
- Right, we've given them,
you know, six years to get into it right.
- Exactly and it's a good amount.
So wait, it's finally summer.
So like in Scotland, do you do like
big summer vacations there?
I love Scotland by the way.
- Yeah, I love Scotland.
Yeah and we, as a child we
used to go on summer vacations
to the beach
but it's not like you
guys here in California.
You know, it's -
- It's like cold.
- It's raining, it's miserable.
You get in the, your mom
makes you get in the water.
You're freezing cold.
The first thing you wanna do
is get out and get in the car.
But of course, you know, then you -
- Why does she make you get in?
- I know like it's
supposed to be fun right?
- Yeah, okay, frolic, yeah.
- Yeah, so it's nice to come to the U.S.
and actually have a proper beach vacation.
- It can be cold here too.
I took my kids to the beach
the other day and it was maybe
not comparatively speaking,
but they were like, "Get in."
And I was like, "No, hard pass."
I was like, "It's really cold."
Do you surfer at all?
Or do anything like that?
- I have done a little in the U.S.
and actually recently on my show
that I created "Men in Kilts".
- Yeah, I love that, yeah.
- We.
- We have you on your,
yeah with it on there, yeah.
- We did a little surfing in
Scotland, which is amazing
because people don't
really think of surfing
in Scotland right.
And actually it's amazing.
You get to the beach,
there's no one there.
So you get, you get the
whole thing to yourself.
'Cause it's cold, yeah.
- Yeah, I'm not really
selling Scotland here am I?
- No, I love Scotland, but I love rain.
So it rains a lot.
I love that.
- It does it, I think we've
got about 20 different words
for rain and stuff.
- I know.
Are they curse words?
- They are pretty much.
- You're like over it.
I love rain.
I grew up in Texas, so I love rain.
But have you been able
to explore like more
than just L.A.?
Like in the U.S.?
- I've been all over, yeah.
- Oh yeah?
- I mean actually when
I first came to America
I traveled all around the U.S. by bus.
- Oh.
- And one of the experiences
I had is I actually went
to Texas and -
- Really?
- Yes, yes.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- We're nice.
- Yeah. I remember nothing, yeah.
- Oh, well.
- I met some very friendly.
- So you went to some bars.
- Yeah, I went to this bar
but it was like underground in a ranch
and I just, I tell -
- In Texas you gotta be
careful who you're going
underground with.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, they were very friendly
people I have to admit.
- Yeah, we are friendly, we are friendly.
- Yeah.
- But is there anything
about America that's still weird to you?
Like we drive on the
other side, obviously.
- Yeah, you do drive on the other side.
Actually. I love that.
I learned to drive at a very late age
and have probably driven more in the U.S.
than I have in the UK.
So, it kind of feels right
to be on the right hand side
of the road but you guys
have the four way stop thing.
That is.
- Yeah
- Yeah, no, I love a roundabout.
- Oh, I like a roundabout.
- Yeah, right, this.
- Yep, yep, yep.
Oh, I get what you're saying.
I guess, yeah.
You only need two stops really.
And the other can wait, I guess.
- Right, I dunno, I just,
I, you always have to wait
for the the person on the four way stop.
And that confuses me.
- In Texas, it's hard too.
'cause everyone's polite.
So it's like, "No, you go.
- Right, do you go.
- "No, you go."
And you're there forever, yeah.
- You get nowhere, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was a look at season
six of his Outlander
which you can see on Starz.
So congratulations on another season.
- Thank you.
- People love this show
so much, Outlander.
(audience applauding and cheering)
So for those people living
under a rock that have never
seen Outlander, like
explain your character.
Like what what's going on in this season.
If you're, if you dunno.
Yes, where have you been?
- Where have you been?
- Yes.
- But I mean maybe someone, I don't know.
- Yeah, well we're starting
season six is sort of picking
up short time after
the end of season five.
Claire is suffering the
trauma that happened to her
from the last season.
We've got the the War of
Independence is fast approaching
and Jamie is also dealing
with an old adversary in
the form of Tom Christie.
So there's so much going
on at the very beginning.
- Yeah, oh my God it's such a good show.
Thank you, mom.
My mom is one who said and my sister.
- Oh thank you.
- Yeah, it was years ago.
I was like, this is awesome.
I just love mystic time travel.
I'm into it.
So is it true though that
y'all had, I've heard this
this is like the third time
I think I've asked an actor
this on the show.
There's now intimacy coaches,
- Right.
- On set.
It's like a thing now
that you have to have.
- Yeah.
- Is it more intimidating
or more helpful?
- Oh, absolutely helpful.
Yeah.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I introduced our
coach to the production
and honestly, you know,
we were quite naive,
quite young when we first started.
Young and I was all.
We were young when we started
and we just, we were kind of dropped
in the deep end, you know.
We had to sort of work
it out for ourselves.
Now we have someone who's
there to help advise,
to help guide us and not just ourselves,
but the younger members
of the cast as well.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah.
- So, oh yeah.
That's when we were young.
- It can be, it can be
awkward though, I imagine.
- Right, yeah, yeah.
- So that's kind of,
I think it would like help you
compartmentalize a little more.
Like if you have someone
there being almost
you know, like scientific
with it or whatever.
- I takes you as the
actor out of the equation
and makes it easier to just get into this
because it can be quite
awkward for not only the actors
but the crew who have to stand there
- Yeah.
- And watch you guys for hours.
- I can compartmentalize.
Well, it'll be fine.
Okay, so Outlander fans
have sent some art.
I feel like people, anytime
something is such a big thing
in pop culture, there's all these
like super fans that always
make all this cool art.
- Right.
- So have you received any of that?
- I've received all kinds of things from
I know a duvet with my
face all over it, which is.
- Now wait, did they think you
were gonna sleep with that?
'Cause like, would you wanna sleep?
Do you sleep
with your face?
- I mean, absolutely,
of course.
(Kelly laughing)
Hi me, good night.
Yeah, to little dolls of
us to crochet pictures.
It's a and very creative, very creative.
- Oh my gosh.
That's so funny though.
- Should get you a duvet as well.
- Yeah, I'll just snuggle
up real tight with it.
I always think it's funny though.
Sometimes when they do give
you art and it's like your face
and it's like, well it's flattering,
but like what am I am I
like, am I supposed to put it
in my house and be like,
"So this is my face."
Like, you know, like it's
like, it's awesome though
how talented they are.
I can't draw or anything.
Are you good at anything?
Other artistic thing?
- I'm not really,
My mom's an artist actually.
So I should, I should be.
But no I'm useless.
- What kind of artist is she?
- She makes paper and.
- What?
- Craft like pottery
and stuff like that.
She does all kinds of things, yeah.
- That's cool.
- And sculpture, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
I think your mom just trumped you.
She's kind of cool.
- Yeah, all I've got is
the duvet with my face on.
- And an intimacy coach.
- All right.
- That's not exciting.
So wait Katrina's character
time travels on the show.
If you could time
if you could do that, like
where, when would you go?
- Oh, I think the future,
I always wanted to travel.
I wanted to travel in space, you know?
I mean, we're starting to explore more.
I'd love to go to.
- Oh, you'd go to the future.
- I'd go to the future, yeah.
- Me too.
Well women in general
past wasn't great so.
- No.
- So, so yeah.
I'd go to the future too.
- Where, how far?
- I wanna, I'm kind of
sad that I don't know
if we'll be I know
right alive when they go
to Mars and do that kind of yeah
- I know.
Well, didn't Elon Musk say
he wanted to die on Mars?
- Yeah, he, yeah.
- That's a bit weird.
- I don't really wanna
start a sentence with
"I wanna die." like anywhere.
- No, no.
- Yeah.
- I'd rather live and go to
Mars and then I come back.
- I wanna live, I wanna frolic
like, I wanna skip on Mars.
That's what I wanna do.
- I'm not sure you can skip.
Or if you did you might
just keep going.
- Or in a suit, yes.
Go to the next planet.
That's amazing.
I think it's exciting though.
Space, like how he wants
to do like, you know
live in different.
I think that's exciting.
- Right?
I love, I'm really
kinda obsessed with that
and I love all these
kind of new experiences
you can go and get,
go into the atmosphere or
the stratosphere or whatever.
- Yeah like orbit, like, yeah.
I think that's really
cool too, I'm into that.
But I think, yeah, we're
gonna miss that unfortunately.
Get on it Elon.
So I have to ask you about the. (laughing)
We wanna go.
- Just sign up.
- I have to ask about this.
So you recently made a
movie with Celine Dion.
- Yes, right?
- What?
Come on, right?
- I know.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- First of all, she's one
of my favorite singers
of all time.
But like I didn't know that she,
I didn't, well, how did this happen?
- She might now become
your favorite singer
and actress 'cause it's her
first time I think acting
in a movie and she's so good.
- Yeah?
- She's really funny.
She plays herself, but she's really good.
And, then she's supplied a lot
of the music for the movie as well.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
She's so, have you seen her Vegas show?
- I haven't seen it.
I'm desperate to go.
- It's incredible.
Okay, I didn't know.
I thought I was gonna, you know
it's just gonna be like classy, like yeah.
Like just big songstress whatever.
She dances.
She's like so passionate.
- Yeah.
- It's so good.
- She's incredible, yeah.
- Yeah, it's incredible.
- Yeah, so I'm excited as well..
- Well I know that you sang in the show.
So did you get any attempt?
Did you sing for her?
Please tell me you sang for Celine Dion.
- There may be a little
something in there.
(audience cheering)
- That's amazing.
- Nah, you won't be.
- You won't be? (Kelly laughing)
- You won't be.